[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
andy staples kind enough
to join us on loan from the athletic
covering college football
andy any problems with the final four
not really because it was going to be
notre dame or a
m at four and you could flip a coin on
those two and i don't think anybody
other than the fan bases would have been
upset
if one or the other had been picked
notre dame makes sense you can make the
case hey look they beat a team that's in
the playoff
texas a m had a really good win against
florida but they both got blown out by
teams that are in the playoffs so
i mean it was kind of six to one half
dozen to the other
i just would like it to be a better
system
in general you know it doesn't need to
be four should have been eight all along
and every year they keep it you know
showing us why
it should be eight but you know what
will happen andy you're gonna get some
of these teams that get in there
and they get blown out because they face
alabama or clemson in the opening round
and then
that happens now i i know i did i said
that i said notre dame gets blown out
or a m gets blown out we don't have a
problem with that but if boy if
cincinnati goes in there and gets blown
out that's bad for college football
yeah it's crazy because so if you had an
eight team and this is how they would do
it
it would be your five power five champs
get in
your highest ranked group of five champ
gets in and then two at largest so
the games you'd have you'd have oregon
at alabama oh no by the way you you get
the bulls out of there and you actually
play them
in campus college football stadiums
where they're meant to be played
so you'd have organ at alabama which
people will say okay
why is oregon in there they don't
deserve it okay
but from a business perspective you kept
that side of the country
engaged the entire season you gave
stakes to the pac-12 championship game
and if organ gets blown out great
that's alabama getting a reward for
earning the number one seed
you got cincy at clemson will clemson
kill cincy
maybe but at least we know and then
you have oklahoma at ohio state and
texas a m
at notre dame who is not watching those
games
i know i agree but i don't know when do
they expand because
they have the the contract with espn
can they break that contract i guess all
contracts are meant to be broken but
you know we're we're stuck with this
through what 2023
2026 oh and it's it's the deal with the
bulls this
that's the issue because espn would be
fi espn
wants to make the the conferences happy
if the conferences say we want to do an
18 play off espn will say great
we'll pay you for that because i mean
they're going to wind up paying about
the same amount of money anyway
you slice it so they don't care about
the packaging
they just care about the product so if
you give them an opportunity to buy the
product they'll buy it
but it's the deal with the bowls because
you know you've got these middlemen in
the bulls that have been
for years hijacking the way college
football crowns as national champion
they were pretty useful back in the day
they're completely useless now
there is no need for them to be there if
the school let's say the rose bowl
here's here's a good example because the
rose bowl has always kind of been
what was in the way and if you went to
the rose bowl right now and said
hey we're going to have a big 10 and
pac-12 game in your stadium
we're going to kick it off at two
o'clock eastern time on january 1st
it's not gonna be a playoff game we're
gonna play those on campus uh
we're not gonna give you as much money
as we did before uh espn's gonna give
all that money to the conferences
the roseville would say well no we don't
want to do that and they'll say okay
that's great we're going to move that
game to another stadium and now you can
have zero dollars and enjoy your monster
truck pull on january 1st
and the rose bowl will be like okay
we'll take
some dollars over zero dollars that
would be wonderful and now we have the
rose bowl in dallas
can we call it the rose bowl i'm not
clear on the legality of this
i don't know if i'm gonna get a letter
from somebody
i know it's um hey you know we got
caught up in this eye
test and and uh i i still don't know i
don't have great vision but
you know the eye test with ohio state
i want him in there in the final four
but i can't sit there and go boy they
passed the i test
you know who passes the eye test as
strange as this is going to sound
florida does if florida didn't lose to
lsu
i mean that they went toe-to-toe with
alabama if you said they were going to
play again
i'd say absolutely i'm all in yeah you
know that loss to lsu i wonder
was there if if they didn't lose to lsu
would there be a chance that florida was
in there instead of notre dame
it would have been the 2018 discussion
all over again
remember in 2018 alabama and georgia
play the the really good sec
championship game where tua gets hurt
jalen hurts comes in
and there was the big argument of do you
put georgia in at number four
even though they just lost alabama i
think you would had that same discussion
had florida not lost to lsu
the problem for florida is yeah you just
showed you can go toe-to-toe with
alabama but a week earlier you just
showed you can completely
lay an egg so i mean that that's the
issue
with that one but yeah your that would
have been the dominant conversation
sunday morning
if florida hadn't lost to lsu is should
florida be number four
you okay with ohio state just because
yeah i am and and
here's the thing everybody's like well
you you got to punish them punish the
big ten because they only played six
games
yeah but if you punish the big ten by
punishing ohio state that makes no sense
the big ten played at all because ohio
state
and nebraska and iowa and those people
fought
to get a season played in the big ten
ohio state would have loved to have
played 10 games
they were on the side of the acc and the
sec and the big 12 the entire time
so you can't punish them because their
league did something stupid
so i'm fine with it and look it was all
gonna be i test anyway because we didn't
have non-conference games
we didn't get remember we're supposed to
get ohio state oregon in week two
that would have been amazing it would
have been a great data point for us to
tell
okay where's the pac-10 stack up against
the big ten
we we don't have any idea this year
because we didn't have
any non-conference games and so the only
only thing we can really say is the sun
belt is better than the big 12 because
the sun belt went 3-0 against the big
12.
army is not going to a bowl game their
head coach is going to join his top of
the hour so
to explain this to me that army what are
they eight and two
not going to a bowl game so basically
they were going to the independence bowl
and that was set up and the end of
principle
had to cancel its game because it can't
get
another team into the game uh there have
been too many opt-outs and so
the independence bowl does not have an
opponent for them and
all the other bulls because they're
contractually tied to different
conferences
had to fill through the different
conferences that they're contractually
tied to
and it's a great injustice because army
deserves to be there
you know you've got a two-in south
carolina playing in a bowl and army's
not playing in a bowl
it's ridiculous and it's interesting
because army's former commandant is the
president of south carolina
you'd think he'd say look out of respect
we're gonna stay home
and you guys go play in the bowl game
and i i you know
you don't want anybody to have any
issues with kova 19 but if somebody does
and it seems like given the number of
teams
that are playing in bulls there's a
chance somebody does let's throw army in
there if somebody can
has to back out let them play in a bowl
game they've earned it
yeah and that's why i go back to this
when people say
oh you know these uh schools that aren't
in the power five conferences
you know they wouldn't be able to go
toe-to-toe with these uh schools that
are and i go
let me take you back to army on the road
against oklahoma and kyler murray and
went into overtime
so it's it's one game and maybe there's
a blowout
but you tell me oklahoma came out of
that game going man we're so much better
than army
no and army took michigan to the limit
the following year
look army's a good team there's no
reason army shouldn't be in a bowl game
and
i this is another one of my issues with
the bull system in general
again you don't need these middlemen
like espn owns and operates 17 bowls now
you got the myrtle beach bowl coming on
later today conway south carolina on the
surf turf at coastal carolina
those bulls have no middlemen espn puts
it on
the teams show up and you're good to go
and that's
the way they could do it throughout
college football if they wanted to
and just set up the best matchups you
can instead of having well we gotta have
big ten number three versus sec number
four
don't do that if anything this season
taught us
that things might be better if you
schedule a little more on the fly anyway
and that coastal carolina byu game was
set up on two days notice
it was probably the best game of the
season so why not have it where
the leagues get together with espn
and say we're going to create 39
postseason games
and but we're not going to set them up
by conference or anything like that
we're just going to match them up
for the best possible matchups the best
television matchups the most deserving
teams get the best games
and that's how you do it everybody would
be it
would be fine with that viewers would
love it and you don't give money to
people who don't
do anything and you're making money wait
yes
andy you're making way too much i know
you gotta stop you gotta stop with this
because you know what in 365 days andy
we're probably having this same
conversation oh
100 and probably more so and
more frustrated because they will have
gone back to
all of the old ways of doing things it
will be we must schedule non-conference
games 12 years in advance because that
is what we do we must do that but you
don't have to do that if this year
taught us anything
you don't have to do any of the things
that you thought you had to do
so think about it if you're gonna
if you're gonna press the reset button
now would be a great time
it's great to talk to you as always we
appreciate your insights uh merry
christmas happy holidays to you andy and
thank you for joining us
thank you dan that's andy staples and he
works for the athletic